we're told an electronic circuit has two
resistors with resistances
r1 and r2 connected in
parallel the circuit's total resistance
r sub t or rt is given by this
formula suppose we increase the value of
r1 while keeping r2 constant
what does the does the value of r sub t
increase
decrease or stay the same so pause this
video and see if you can answer this
question
all right now let's work through this
together and some of you might be
familiar with the idea of an electronic
circuit
and resistors and what they represent
but you really don't need to understand
that in order to
understand what's going on in this
expression there's some quantity
r sub t that's equal to one over
and then in the denominator we have one
over r one plus one over r two
so if we increase the value of
r 1 while keeping r2 constant what
happens
so this is going to increase and r2 is
going to be constant
so one way to think about it we have two
variables here in
especially in this denominator but
really in this entire expression but if
r2
is going to be constant we really just
have to focus
our analysis on r1 our if r2 is constant
that means it's just a number it could
be 2
it could be 5 it could be pi whatever
but that is not going to change
as we increase the value of r1 so let's
think about what's happening here
if r sub 1 increases
then what does that do to 1 over
r1 well if you increase the denominator
then you're going to decrease the
reciprocal of that
so that means that this whole thing
right over here is going to
decrease now if 1 over r1 is decreasing
if 1 over r1 is decreasing
what's going to happen to 1 over r1
plus 1 over r2 will this entire
expression
increase or decrease well this part is
staying constant
r2 is constant so 1 over r2 is constant
just imagine r2 could be 2 or 3 so this
should just be one half or 1 3 or
whatever it is
while over here this part of the
expression is going down
so if you're taking the sum of two
things one part's going down the other
part's constant then that means this
whole thing
is going to be going down so the entire
denominator of this entire thing
is going down now the entire denominator
is going down if 1 over r1
plus 1 over r2 if this whole thing
is going down what's going to happen to
the reciprocal of that
1 over 1 over r1 plus 1 over r2
well if something is going down the
reciprocal of that
is going to go up if you get smaller and
smaller denominators
one over that is going to be a larger
and larger value
so the value of rt increases
if r1 increases and r2
is constant and for those of you who
know about resistance which
is really how how how well
a current can flow through a circuit
that will also make intuitive sense but
you don't need to understand
resistance to analyze this
mathematically